Hello I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow-Mo Guys.
This is circulating.
Yeah. I mean, you may have seen someone
very, very stupid eating
corn with a drill.
Yeah.
This is Slow Mo Guys,
so obviously we're not the
most intelligent people.
Although,
No, I am gonna give it a go.
Rhett and Link did this,
so it must be smart in some way.
Okay. I'll take it, I'll take it.
So, hopefully it doesn't destroy my teeth
and we'll see what happens, shall we?
Bit of ketchup?
Sure, yeah.
Hopefully your hair won't get pulled out,
your jaw won't get knocked off.
My teeth won't fall out,
and it'll taste nice.
Let's hope for the best.
All right, lathering it on there.
Yeah, I don't want to have a gap.
You're getting a perfect, even...
I should do this
professionally, look at this.
This is great. I'm like a rotisserie here.
I haven't dropped any.
I'm quite impressed with you.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I didn't realize we're
getting so much ketchup
on a piece of corn.
Oh my goodness.
Okay I think that's enough.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Okay.
Go for it.
What a fail.
Wow!
Ketchup flying, you can see all the corn
going into my mouth, can you see that?
Yeah.
Just all going in there.
It's great.
It's going everywhere.
It's awful to look at.
It's so much more gross then in real life.
Look at all that corn.
If it wasn't for the ketchup, I'd be fine.
I can't believe you had
that much in your mouth,
it's never ending.
It's a whole damn lot
of it, finished it off,
absolutely polished.
You polished it, it's unbelievable.
That might be the most efficient way
to eat a corn on a cob.
Efficient?
Yeah sure.
Missed a couple of bits, I'll take it.
Not the most attractive video
we've ever maid, I'll tell you that.
Apart from me vomiting I think.
Yeah.
Well a big thanks to all a thousand of you
who tweeted that to us, to do it.
It was a fantastic idea, I
think it look tremendous.
Not tremendous to me,
that was disgusting.
How do you store so much of that?
It's like entire cob.
I was hoping you didn't
know I had that in my mouth,
I was just like yeah.
It was so much.
Alright, well that was a different one,
but we love it, we love
all kinds of slow mo's.
Oh god.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt if you want, and
subscribe to The Slow Mo Guys
and maybe you'll see more of this kind
of thing in the future, but hopefully not.
Good lord that was gross.
You want ketchup with that?
Absolutely not.
I do not want ketchup with that.